hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy and I'm here with Grace Hoyt
head of account security Partnerships at
Google to talk a little bit about Online
safety welcome Grace
thanks for having me Sal so let's just
start at the basics what is Online
safety and what's the worst that could
happen
as we spend more of our Times online we
think about Online safety in a way that
people can go about their work or school
or personal activities online in a way
that they feel safe and secure and a big
Topic in this space that we like to
provide guidance on is something called
online scams and in particular how to
avoid phishing
now fishing spelled with a pH
p-h-i-s-h-i-n-g what what is that I I it
it starts to evoke you know people are
maybe fishing for me
that's right Sal fishing is does have
the namesake from the word with uh
fishing with an f
um but this fishing we're talking about
is a attempt to impersonate someone
um a trusted Source or reach you via
email phone or call and try to get
access to someone's personal information
such as their bank account information
their passwords or address and things
like that so phishing is a way to sort
of beat and hook someone into giving up
personal information unfortunately about
80 percent of all cyber attacks begin
with fishing so this is something we
think it's really important for people
to be able to spot and recognize on
their own so that this doesn't happen to
them and what form do these phishing
attacks take
so these can be emails
um impersonating a trusted Source these
can come in the form of spammy text
links or phone calls
one of the most important tips that we
like to advise people is to not click on
a URL link before verifying that it
really is the source you're trying to
get to so it's always best to actually
go directly to a website for example if
you're trying to reach your bank or
track the delivery of a package type
that directly into your url as opposed
to opening a suspicious link right out
of your email inbox or a text message
now if you want to actually look more
closely at a link before clicking on it
on mobile you can press and hold down on
the URL and look for suspicious aspects
of that link or typos but you can also
just use the option to go directly to
that link yourself as opposed to opening
it out of something that looks
suspicious okay so this has definitely
happened to me in the recent past where
I get these text messages for fraud
alert for your bank account and
sometimes it's from a bank where I don't
even have a bank account so they're just
trying to see if I happen to be you know
someone just charged ten thousand
dollars like oh my God and then I look
at it and and the URL looks a little bit
Shady to your point you have to really
confirm what the URL is even if it
doesn't look shady and on mobile you can
you can press and hold sometimes you get
these emails and hey someone has just
done the following on your Amazon
account go log into your Amazon account
here and and it's probably a link to a
fake Amazon website you type in your
credentials now they can actually log in
to your Amazon account or your a banking
account or whatever else
absolutely so unfortunately that's often
times a way that folks are trying to
grab that password and have you hand it
over to them so you're you're exactly
right Sal so we do recommend that people
go straight to that URL well thanks for
that I think we're all a little bit less
likely to get fished and get hooked